you guys are so iconic i mean this show
is
legendary but of course with that comes
what i would imagine to be
a hard life in the spotlight for each of
you
being in the public eye for so long what
has been the hardest part and is there
anything that you want people
to know i see jenny thinking over there
i mean first of all we're super grateful
like
we appreciate every fan out there
without
without them there wouldn't have been a
show it's such a fun like a cool thing
to think like
what do you have that you passed down to
the next generation and for so many
families and women out there
it's our show and that's just a cool
thing to be a part of especially raising
women ourselves
i think that fans are the least of your
concerns as a celebrity
um you do it the reason why you do what
you do
and um i think like all the other
stuff that comes with being in the
industry
that we're in you have to learn how to
handle it you have to
learn what works for you and what
doesn't
and what works for tory might not work
for me and vice versa
but we learned at such a young age
that i think we really have an advantage
because we know what we're dealing with
we know the beast
we just know how to survive like that
sure we've developed really thick skin
for 30 years having to just deal with
you know all the amazing stuff but also
the negative people too
you know nowadays it's social media and
cyber bullying
but we had our version of it back then
it was just very different but
yeah you just have to navigate it and
not take things personally which is
still really hard
but you guys do it and you do it with
grace will your kids re-watch with you
do you feel like they're of age two have
they ever seen the show
my girls have seen it yeah they're older
and they've all watched
most of it if not all of it but they
loved it and it's crazy how they watch
it and it still it stands the test of
time like it's so
relevant to them what is happening and
they're still like enthralled and can't
wait for the next episode so i think
that's cool
yeah tori what about free i feel like i
feel like when they watched it they
thought you were cooler
yeah they had a new appreciation for you
that was nice to watch my kids are
younger
so when the little like my oldest or 12
and 13
when they watched it i tried to show
them once and they didn't
recognize me from the show they were
like there's they found jenny right away
and they were like where are you and
what so yeah
that traumatized me a little bit uh and
i was like i don't look that much older
so
uh but now like with bh 90210 happening
last summer
and they got to you know hang out with
the rest of the cast and the
calf kids like they were all together on
set all summer
they really got back into watching it so
my oldest two
um they're still in season one but okay
all right they'd rather watch full house
old
uh episodes but what kind of
i'm gonna tell candace cameron that
that's so funny tori you shared this
amazing picture i think it was you jenny
and brian austin green
and you just said what amazing parents
they are of course
brian's been in the media a lot lately
megan fox
has questioned why he's using his
children on social media
anything you want to say to his
character and how you think he is as a
parent
both of us are very protective and this
will definitely be something that will
probably bring up on the podcast
but that picture was kind of unrelated i
think
we're starting to bring up old pictures
and rounds wino and the cast and because
we're starting the podcast
and it was just kind of nostalgic and i
um i actually was just looking through
pictures from
last year when we did bh9o and i found
that picture
and i was just having a moment where i
was thinking how proud i am
of these two people that
were you know my childhood friends and
you know one's a man once a woman and
they're both such
dynamic parents um
that really do it like they do it all
and i i don't know i was just having a
moment
jenny how did you feel seeing that post
i mean she praised you as well
i know she's always so nice being a mom
is my
favorite thing to do so it's so nice to
hear that you think i'm doing it well
tour thank you
i've loved to over the years watching
you be a mom i
never ever in my wildest dreams thought
you have five kids
but i love it and i love each one of
them
um and just watching you grow into
the person you have to be to raise five
children
it's it's so nice to see it but also
like
jen and brian and i were the youngest so
that's why the three of us have this
really special bond and to have gone on
this
journey and now be parents to so many
kids between the three of us
that um it's just yeah i i mean i could
never have pictured brian being
the type of dad he is you know he was a
little boy
that's a lot of kids 11 kids
12. oh sorry
yeah i'm pretty good at math she's not
good at math
that is so exciting though you're right
and and it does seem like he's a good
dad so
i like that he's an awesome dad this new
podcast idea is so
exciting especially for someone like me
a super fan
um how did the idea come about what
inspired it
i think we sort of started to get really
nostalgic
when we uh we learned it was the 30th
anniversary of the original show
and just we got to be with each other
um a lot last summer and it we need to
continue that we have so much fun
working together so we're always looking
for opportunities to
put projects together that we can be
hang out with each other on
when was the last time that you guys
actually went back to the beginning
and watched the series i mean from that
first episode
we haven't you've never gone back and
watched it's gonna happen
with with our listeners
you